[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROMAN NURIK: Hello, and welcome
once again, yet again,
to Android Design in Action.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hi guys.
My name's Adam Koch.
NICK BUTCHER: And hi, my
name's Nick Butcher.
ROMAN NURIK: And Nick is joining
us from Mountain View
today, not rainy London, since
he's actually visiting the
core Android Developer
Relations team
out in Mountain View.
Nick, how is Mountain View?
NICK BUTCHER: I'm in San
Francisco right now, so you've
got a nice view of
my hotel bedroom.
Because it's 7:00 AM here.
ROMAN NURIK: Nice.
Well, thanks for joining so
early in the morning, Nick.
So today's episode of Android
Design in Action, we're going
to talk about news readers.
We're not going to look at any
specific apps since we're
still figuring out how we
approach nominations for apps
that want to get
some redesigns.
We'll be talking about kind of
hypothetical stuff for news
readers, and then we'll jump
into units of measures--
specifically,
density-independent pixels as
well as some layout grids and
pixel grids and all sorts of
fun stuff like that.
With that, shall
we get started?
ADAM KOCH: Let's do it.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So let's talk about
news readers.
So previously on Android Design
in Action, I think a
few months ago, maybe in
January, actually, we did an
episode on iterative
improvements.
Basically starting from a very
bare bones news reader type
app that basically had a list
very bacon-y articles and a
details section that let you
kind of view the details or
read that article.
And we figured, why not just
kind of use that as a starting
point and see how we can
improve on the reading
experience from there?
So here are some slides from
the last episode of Android
Design in Action.
And you can see that you have
this list of articles on the
left, your news items.
And then on a tablet, of
course, you have this
multipane UI, where you have
the list of articles on the
left and then your details
on the right.
And then on a phone, you
just have your details.
Usually a photo, a title, and
then obviously the meat of the
article, which is a
big block of text.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGHS]
Meat of the article.
Was that a joke?
ROMAN NURIK: What?
ADAM KOCH: Boom-boom, chhh.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, the meat
of the-- oh, right.
ADAM KOCH: Didn't
even realize it.
ROMAN NURIK: I said and pun and
didn't even realize it.
But yes.
NICK BUTCHER: Sorry.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
And then we also did some
alternatives where, let's see,
we really want to focus
on the photos.
Here are some things
you can do.
You can make the photo kind of
full bleed and let the article
the text be an overlay
on top of that.
And there are a couple things
that we talked about,
including background protection
with dark gradients
and things of that nature.
So these are just two of the
presentations that we threw
together for detailed.
So today I wanted to talk
about alternative
presentations of these things,
as well as enhancements, I
guess further iterative
improvements on this
experience that can really make
news reading a pleasure.
So let's jump into
some of those.
The first is--
and this is actually kind
of a power user feature.
We probably should've
saved this for last.
But back with Android 4.1, we
provided this new feature
called expanded notifications.
So you have your collapsed
notifications, and then with a
two-finger gesture, you pull
down to expand a notification
to see more details.
With recent versions of Android,
you can actually just
use a single finger to swipe
down if there aren't that many
notifications on the list.
So one of the things that they
were thinking about is as
you're browsing a set of
stories, as you're browsing
this list, oftentimes you want
to get a little more.
You don't want to necessarily
read the entire article or see
everything.
You just want to get a slightly
larger preview.
So there are a couple of ways
of doing that, if that's of
interest to you in your
news reader app.
Obviously, you could have a
button within that list item,
like a preview button.
You could potentially have
a long-press preview, or
long-press to show a contextual
action bar, and
then you could have
a preview there.
But we thought, this is maybe
a power user thing.
Once you discover it, you start
using it a little more.
So why not use a power
user gesture?
So one way of doing this is,
let's say you use your two
fingers to swipe down
on an article.
You'd swipe down and then you'd
start seeing the preview.
So in this case, it's a video.
The video maybe even starts
playing inline automatically.
And this is something that you
can definitely do as of
Android 4.0.
Or actually even Android 3.0.
Actually, no, it's 4.0 point out
that we had this thing--
NICK BUTCHER: TextureView's
4.0, yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: TextureView, that
lets you basically play video
or do lots of interesting things
inside of a graphical
object that's composed with
the rest of your window.
But the idea is that you
can do cool things
like play video inline.
You could apply animations
transitions to video.
But here's one example of where
you could take video and
make it inline.
Alternatively, if you just have
text or a photo, as you
swipe down to expand, you could
show the text, obviously.
You could show a photo, maybe
even horizontally swipeable,
unless you have another
competing gesture for
horizontal swipe.
But it's just the idea that
sometimes a simple little
title that's probably ellipsized
is just not enough.
So this is one way of
alleviating that.
NICK BUTCHER: It's a really
fun power gesture.
I like the use of it in
the list context.
Because as you say, horizontal
swipe is competing for a lot
of different gestures that
are going on in the
space at the moment.
So this is a very nice way to
act on a single list item.
ADAM KOCH: It's really
good for power users.
But then for users that want to
browse normally, it doesn't
interfere with that
flow either.
They can just tap and move
into the article as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Right, it's not
like the only way of exposing
the content.
You can actually just touch
to get to the content.
That's the primary gesture
involved there.
But for the power users that
discover it, it's maybe an
additional nice thing.
NICK BUTCHER: It probably
bootstraps on the rich
notification as well, right?
You're probably going to show a
similar amount of content as
you might be preparing already
and laying out for a rich
notification.
And then it builds on that same
gesture, so you kind of
bootstrap the interaction,
which is cool.
ROMAN NURIK: As an additional
thing, maybe to kind of hint
at the gesture-- and this is
something we talked about a
while ago, with swipe
to dismiss.
With swipe to dismiss, it's not
necessarily a very, very
discoverable gesture
on its own.
But let's say you also provide
the ability to long press on
an object and then press the
Delete Item in the contextual
action bar, and it
slides away.
That hints subtly that hey, I
can do that same thing with my
finger, not necessarily just
always use the Delete action
in the contextual action bar.
But I can actually try this with
my finger, and it works.
So in this case, what you could
do is as these list
items populate, you could
animate them in.
So start with a larger size
and then as they fall into
place, they shrink into the
collapsed size, just to hint
that there's actually more under
each list item and that
you can get to it with your
two-finger swipe.
But lots of different things
you can do here.
The basic point is
make the news
browsing experience great.
Not only the news reading
experience, but the news
browsing experience.
Along the same lines, consider
alternative presentations for
your collection.
So when you present a
list of articles--
or, I guess, a collection of
articles, since it's not
always a list--
consider ways to make that
a richer experience.
So one of the things that we
looked at in the past is
Pocket, which switches--
on a phone, it's a list.
On a 7-inch tablet,
it's a grid.
On a 10-inch tablet, it's kind
of like a staggered grid,
where a single cell can
take multiple columns.
In that same vein, how can you
make this a little more rich?
So one of the alternatives,
obviously, is to make this
full bleed, or almost full
bleed photos and
just the text on top.
And in cases where you don't
have a photo, you could use a
standard background like that.
This works really well for very,
very graphically rich
news content pieces.
It doesn't really work
so well for text.
But certainly, if you have lots
of photos or videos, this
is a good way of
presenting it.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah one of our
core design principles is that
pictures are faster
than words.
And this is an excellent
demonstration of it.
If you have the imagery,
then shout about it.
Make it as big as you can.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, it's definitely
frustrating when a
news app has really great
imagery, and they even use
this list view one, and they
have tiny little images there.
So both of these presentations
look really nice.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Tiny photos is definitely
a pet peeve,
especially on a tablet.
It's such a beautiful screen.
Like a Nexus 10, it's such
a beautiful screen.
And not using it to show photos
if you have really
high-res photos is kind of
a missed opportunity.
NICK BUTCHER: On a side note
to this as it relates to
pattern as well.
One of the things I really like
for using this pattern is
the use of a zoom-up animation
if you click on one of the
tiles through a tag context.
Android makes it really easy to
click on of those squares,
and it zooms up.
So the picture becomes
the whole screen.
And that's super-simple
to build.
It's like two lines of code,
called Activity Options.
And it really will change
your context.
You really have that link
between where you came from
and where you're going to.
ADAM KOCH: That's
a good point.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, moving on.
The next thing we wanted to talk
about was the very much
commented or buzzed about
navigation drawer pattern.
So what you could do is, let's
say you have an app that has
lots of hierarchy.
What you could do is you
could have a spinner.
You could have a drill-down
list navigation where
basically, when you first get to
the app, you have a list of
categories.
And then you touch the category
to get into the
details of that, to see all the
articles within that category.
But what we've been using in
some of our apps recently--
and I'm sure all of you
out there now--
is this new pattern that we're
calling the navigation drawer.
So the navigation drawer is
basically this thing that kind
of slides out from the left.
It's also called the sliding
menu or the fly-in menu.
And it can work really
well where you have
lots of sibling sections.
It's really primarily
for navigation.
It'll work really well when
you have lots of adjacent
sections that don't really work
well as tabs, and maybe
they're too heavyweight
for a spinner.
And the other nice thing
about the navigation--
NICK BUTCHER: Or it gets to
be too many, I think.
ROMAN NURIK: Sorry.
Go ahead, Nick.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, sorry.
It's simply too many, as well.
I think a spinner, you start
maxing out at five, six, seven
items, right?
ROMAN NURIK: So one of the
things that we were thinking
about, and this is something
that comes up frequently, is
what if I have a really,
really deep,
heavy hierarchy, right?
So I have 10 or 20 top-level
sections.
And then within each
section, I have 10
subsections or something.
And if you're a news
organization, you
probably have this.
You probably have a--
ADAM KOCH: It's pretty common
across most news apps, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and also
sports leagues, or any sort of
sports tracking.
You have a bunch of different
leagues with different
subleagues, and categorization
of leagues--
it can be pretty heavyweight.
So what we were thinking about
is, and this is actually
something that we've been
recommending, is letting the
user customize.
So a good example of
this is Currents.
Google Currents has a list of
top-level news categories,
like Sports and Business
and things like that.
But then within each section,
you can actually customize
which news sources you use.
So we took this one
step further.
Let's let the user customize
the entire left pane.
So the navigation drawer is
kind of quick access.
It's the top level
of hierarchy.
Let's give the user the full
customization of that.
So what you see here is an
example of what you could do
if you allow the user
to customize.
So at the very top, you see the
user's favorited sections,
with this Customize button that
lets you change what's
going on there.
When you first open up the app--
let's say you haven't
used it yet--you'd probably just
see Customize, or you'd
just see some pre-canned
items.
NICK BUTCHER: Like Top
News, or whatever.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
And then below that, under More
News or et cetera, et
cetera, you'd see the things
that everybody should see.
Things like Saved Stories,
Featured, Top Videos, whatever.
It's really up to you.
But at the very top is this
heavily customizable section.
So let's take a look.
This is pretty straightforward,
but the more
interesting part is the actual
Customize screen.
So when you press Customize,
what do you see?
This is an example of something
you could build.
So the first thing you
want to do-- and
there's a couple things.
This is basically
list management.
You want to be able
to delete items.
You want to be able to
reorder items, make
things higher than others.
And you want to obviously
be able to add
and search for things.
So we've combined all of
those different tasks
into a single UI.
So on the left, you can notice
that you have these drag
handles for reordering.
And we've highlighted this
before in previous episodes of
the show, I think the one
on shopping lists or
something like that.
And then you can also remove
items using the standard swipe
to dismiss.
We also talked about-- well,
we just mentioned--
swipe to dismiss may not
be super discoverable.
You can absolutely also offer
contextual action.
So if I long press on this
search for Android or long
press on Food & Health, it'll
select those items, and I'll
press delete, and it'll get
them out of the way.
You should also support Undo.
So if that does happen, show
the user the option to undo
what they did, either
contextually in line with the
item or as that bottom bar
that we've shown before.
Additionally, another important
part of this is adding.
Adding a topic or searching
for a topic.
And this is where I think the
bulk of this UI is different
from other current
interactions.
So the idea is that you have
a lot of hierarchy.
And one of the best
ways to flatten
hierarchy is through search.
So you can obviously let the
user drill down into different
levels of hierarchy.
And that can be tedious, but
sometimes it's warranted.
So for that, you would always
see this Browse For More or
Browse item.
So as soon as you give focus
to this Add a Topic text
field, you should
see this Browse.
But as soon as you start typing
in this text field, it
does a global search across
all of the different
categories and subcategories
and sub-subcategories.
And it basically very easily
lets you find what you want
without having to drill down.
The other thing is obviously,
ranking is important here.
Just a brief note
about ranking.
You want to make sure that if
you do use this kind of UI,
you want to make sure that you
rank deeper matches higher
than higher-level matches.
So if you have something like
sports and then soccer, if
you're typing S-O-C, it should
rank higher than the Top
Social Stories, S-O-C there.
The reason for that is that
it's more pertinent.
It's more detailed.
So you always want to show
the more detailed
information up top.
So that's a very fast way
of explaining this.
That's roughly what this works
like or looks like.
Do you guys have any other
suggestions or other ways in
which you can potentially
expose this
kind of large hierarchy?
NICK BUTCHER: Well, you
commented on it earlier on,
but I think in the shopping
episode we did a while back,
you had a really interesting
presentation, an alternative
to this way.
Instead of having the search,
you have a list of art
schools, and then you had
a little View icon.
You could toggle it
the View state.
So that would be an alternative
presentation, if
you didn't have such a very,
very deep hierarchy and you
wanted to be able to present
them to the user, to get them
the knowledge of what
there is available.
What I really like about this
presentation with the search
is not only is it easier to
navigate a very large
structure, but it also makes
it feel more like mine.
The idea of presenting
me some--
given this, and then toggling
it, is very much, here's the
things available to you.
Whereas Search is like, here's
the things I want.
It's a bit more person to me.
I like it.
And I also very much like
the Customize behavior.
I think too many people see
navigation as a way to
advertise every single feature
the app offers.
But having [INAUDIBLE]
very, very small list makes
it, again, more relevant.
So that harks back to our
design principles.
Show me only what I need, when
I need it, which I really,
really like.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
it's just the way to combat very
heavy navigation drawers.
And any time you have
navigation, you want to make
it as light as possible.
You don't want to overburden the
user with stuff that they
have to think about before
they actually
get to their content.
So this is just one of the
easy ways of doing that.
ADAM KOCH: I think when
everyone's using a news app,
not all of the sections
are relevant to you.
So it's just really
nice to be able to
bubble them up quickly.
And if the hierarchy's really,
really deep and really broad,
then it's just hard to find
those items that you want to
add into your Favorites.
I actually haven't seen that
many news apps that really,
really nail that flow of adding
different topics to
your Favorites list.
NICK BUTCHER: Just a
couple notes again
on the sliding drawer.
I know we talked about this
quite a lot in our Design
Hangout, too.
But just while we're here, a
couple of things I really like
about this.
You can see that as the drawer
opens, we change the screen
title and drop the up
caret, and also drop
that Refresh icon.
So it's really important that
you keep the action bar in
place, but you can dynamically
adjust its options to make it
appropriate to when you
have your major
navigation sections open.
And I think another great thing,
talking about that
two-finger swipe-down, because
we're not reserving a
horizontal gesture on the list
view type screen, it means you
could do a whole content swipe
to open this drawer.
So it makes the drawer that
much more discoverable.
So you don't have to just
do an edge type swipe.
You could swipe from anywhere
horizontally within the page
and find the drawer, which is
going to help the users get to
know the app.
We should push on.
We're running late.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah,
that's true.
Oh, that clock is
probably wrong.
OK.
So let's--
we talked about that.
Very quickly, I wanted
to talk about some
very last items here.
So the other thing you want to
obviously optimize is the
article reading experience.
One of the ways in which you can
look at this is there's a
beginning of the article, a
middle of the article, where
you're focusing on the content,
and then the end of
the article, where you're
winding down.
So in the beginning of the
article, you want to see
everything.
You want to see the
action bar.
You want to see the title.
Potentially share options,
it immediately you
want to share something.
But once you start reading, once
you start scrolling down,
one of the things that you could
do is you could actually
first of all, go into Lights Out
mode, where the status bar
and navigation bar go
into a dimmed state.
And potentially, the action
bar can hide.
And this is kind of similar to
the quick-return pattern,
where you start scrolling down
maybe a few hundred pixels or
so, or a few hundred DIPs, and
the action bar slides out of
the way for you.
And then as soon as you start
scrolling back up, you maybe,
going backwards, you may want
to see other options.
So you can show the
action bar again.
This could also be coupled
with touch to toggle the
action bar.
So lots of different things
you can do here.
But the idea is that if the user
doesn't really care about
the actions in that specific
context of reading the text,
you don't necessarily need
to show it, always.
And then once you get to the end
of the article, the action
bar should slide back
in, because it has
that key Share action.
And you see here the
presentation with the Share
action provider that gives you
the most frequently used or
most recently used shared
destination.
And then you also see things
like the comments, obviously,
more in this section.
And you see here, we
kind of expose a
little bit of that hierarchy.
And then Related Stories.
And the only real point here is
that you don't want to have
the entire experience
end there.
If there are things that the
user can really benefit from
at the end of this detail item,
related items or other
things, expose them right there
so that they don't have
to press Back.
The best experience is when
you don't actually have to
press Back or Up or anything.
It's just a continual flow.
You kind of flow through
the app.
So definitely consider doing
this if you have the
opportunity to expose related
items and things like that.
Before we jump into the next
section, any last comments on
news readers or anything?
NICK BUTCHER: No.
That looks great.
ADAM KOCH: Nope.
We should get going.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Let's do it.
So let's jump into
units of measure.
Adam, Nick, do you guys want to
take on units of measure?
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
ROMAN NURIK: So screen
variations.
Go ahead.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
absolutely.
So when we're talk about
designing for Android and the
wealth of different screens
out there, there's a few
things you have to think about
when you talk about different
types of screen.
And the one that most people
tend to lock onto is
resolution.
It's a very well understood
measure, especially coming
from the desktop world.
But when we're talking about
mobile, where devices have
those vastly different
densities of screen,
resolution actually turns out
to be not that useful a
number, in its raw numbers.
Like if you look at two 10-inch
tablets, like the
Motorola Xoom and the Nexus 10,
they have vastly different
resolutions.
Four times the number of
pixels in the Nexus 10.
But they're pretty much very
similar screens, when you're
going to design content that's
going to go onto it, right?
So it turns out that
resolution isn't as
interesting as talking about
size and density.
So luckily, Android has embraced
this from the very
start, and we have this
concept, this kind of
abstraction layer, if you
want, called this
density-independent pixel.
So what this is, as we said
here on the slide, is a
density-independent pixel,
so DP, or we just
generally say DIP.
A DIP is a unit of measure which
keeps things physically
the same size across various
different screens.
So things of certain sizes,
like a finger, is 7
millimeters big on average,
or something like that.
So you want to size your user
interface elements so that
they're roughly the same
physical size across devices.
So that they're easy to tap,
easy to see, and so forth.
So by using this virtualized
unit, this DIP, you don't have
to worry about how many pixels
the screen actually lights up
to display.
You just slide it so that it's
the right virtual size, and
the screen will take
care of it.
ROMAN NURIK: Just one thing I
wanted to mention real quick
is that the core takeaway, I
think, from the rest of this--
if you were going to take one
thing away, it's that as
somebody that's working with
layout or as somebody that's
working with interaction
design, just
forget about pixels.
Pixels don't matter.
For visual design,
pixels matter.
But for layout design,
interaction design, pixels
just don't matter.
Because DIPs are the way in
which you make this entire
world of designing for different
densities sane.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
I will pick up on that.
You kind of sacrifice a little
bit of like precise control in
order to have sanity for dealing
with this vast array
of different devices
out there.
So yeah.
In the example here we're
showing, you have an XHDPI
device, which might use 400
pixels to display an item, and
an MDPI device, which might
actually use 200 pixels.
But they're both the
same physical size,
this 200 DIP measure.
I realize we showed the wrong
device in that picture.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, it's
worth noting.
The Xoom is a device
that's MDPI.
So we've got a Nexus 10 there,
which is actually XHDPI.
ROMAN NURIK: And the Nexus
S is HDPI, not XHDPI.
ADAM KOCH: But just forget
about the [? frame ?].
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Should we move on to the next
slide on calculating DIPs?
You want to talk about
calculating DIPs?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
So the sort of baseline DIP
value is what we call
MDPI, or 160 DPI.
So this is sort of an equation
you can use to calculate
pixels and DIPs and the
sort of conversion
between them all.
So you can basically take
the DPI of a device--
so it may be 160 but it could
be something else.
It could, for example,
be HDPI or XHDPI.
You divide it by the baseline,
which is 160, and then that
gives you your ratio
of pixels to DIPs.
So I don't know if I fumbled any
wording there, but don't
forget-- there's DPI
and there's DIP.
So they're very closely
related.
One is the actual density of the
device, and the other is
these DIP units that we're
talking about.
So hopefully I didn't
fumble anything.
ROMAN NURIK: DPI is dots per
inch, or PPD, pixels per inch.
And then you DIPs, which is
density-independent pixels.
ADAM KOCH: So I think we've
got some sample
calculations here.
NICK BUTCHER: Just to
hammer this home.
ADAM KOCH: Sorry?
NICK BUTCHER: Just to
hammer this home.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, I guess we've
got to move pretty fast here.
So of course, if the DPI of the
device is 160, which is
the standard, then one
pixel equals one DIP.
Straightforward.
If the density of the device is
320, so double the standard
baseline of 160, then one DIP
will equate to two pixels.
NICK BUTCHER: If you're coming
from an iOS would, it's kind
of similar to, like, the
retina is at 2x.
It's the RHDPI.
ROMAN NURIK: So just
one example--
this is actually something that
any time we talk about
DIPs in presentations, we've
asked this question.
So if you look at the Nexus 7
screen resolution, 1280 by
800, it's actually the same as
the Motorola Xoom's screen
resolution, 1280 by 800, and
very similar to the Galaxy
Nexus and Nexus 4's screen
resolution, 1280 by something.
768, 720.
But its DIP resolution
is very different.
So if you plug in these values,
the fact that the
Nexus 7 is 213 DPI and 1280 by
800, you'll actually find that
its DIP resolution roughly
960 by 600 DIPs.
And that helps you figure out
how much content will fit into
this space.
ADAM KOCH: How much screen
real estate is really
available for you to
work with here.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So when you think about screen
real estate, definitely don't
think in pixels.
Think in DIPs.
So yes, Nexus 7, about
960 by 600 DIPs.
And if you're doing any sort of
development, a lot of our
qualifiers, like smallest width,
width and height-- a
lot of the resource qualifiers
that you use are based on this
resolution, not the
pixel resolution.
So make sure that you use this
resolution when looking at the
screen real estate available
on the device.
So with grids, let me just
briefly talk about some of the
grids that you should be using
when you're doing layout.
So once you are in this world of
DIPs, after that, you need
to start thinking about laying
out your elements.
So obviously on Android, you
want to make sure that you use
constraint-based layouts.
So don't say, this should be
exactly 200 DIPs, or this
should be exactly 300,
and that'll be
roughly fill up the space.
Make sure that you're using
things like, this should be
20% of the screen or 20% of
the available real estate.
And then make sure
that you're using
constraint-based layout as well.
Like this should be to the right
of this, and this should
be below that.
But also, you want to use
some basic sizes.
So two of the things that we
generally recommend using, and
two of the things that
we document on
developer.android.com/design,
are our 48-DIP rhythm, which
basically says that roughly,
both vertically and
horizontally, you should try to
structure items around 48
DIPs in width and height.
Especially touch targets.
Touch targets, the minimum size
should really be 48 DIPs.
But 48 DIPs, 96 DIPs, multiples
of 48, things like
that work well.
But with things like spacing and
margins and padding, you
want to try to use roughly
a 4-DIP grid.
So what that means is that the
very smallest amount of space
between two items should
be about 4 DIPs.
Or 0, if it's completely
flush.
But also, it means that you
should use multiples of 4 as
things like margins.
So the margins around your
screen should be
16 DIPs or 32 DIPs.
And then in some cases, you
want to use 8-DIP spacers.
So what I generally do
as a designer is I
use 4 DIPs very rarely.
I use mostly either 0, 8, or
16 as my primary paddings.
And then on tablets, I actually
use larger ones.
So like 16 or 32 or
things like that.
So in general, think in terms
of multiples of 4.
And then think about this
48-DIP rhythm, where
everything should really just
align to multiples of 48, in a
perfect world.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't know if
you picked up on it, but a lot
of the system UI we use
is 48-DIP rhythm.
So if you've got software
navigation on the Nexus 4, we
have the Back and
Home buttons.
That's 48 DIPs high.
The action bar is
48 DIPs high.
So falling into the rhythm of
this layout means that your
app will kind of fit in with the
rhythm of the page, kind
of gestalt principles.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
All right.
Let's move on.
So here's just a sample of
some of our layouts.
Nick, you want to talk
about that red line?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
So as you were saying earlier,
when you're talking about
layout, when you're talking
about what you're going to put
on a page, you want to forget
about physical pixels and you
want to work in DIPs.
So say you want to prepare a
layout for like a 10-inch type
device, that size of screen.
Then you don't want to think
about the raw pixels.
You want to create your canvas,
using an Illustrator
or Photoshop or Fireworks,
whatever it might be, to the
DIP size and work
at this baseline
resolution of DIP size.
So then when you do your layout,
like the red line like
we're showing here-- the
items are at 1 pixel.
Therefore, it translates
straight into 1 DIP.
So it's really, really easy to
do your layout at this to
resolution and communicate
that to your developers.
Hand them these red lines and
show them that these are the
size and depth that
things need to be.
ROMAN NURIK: It also works well
with red lining tools.
There are some tools for
Fireworks, like Inspector,
something like that, that
actually create these red
lines for you.
Not these exact ones.
But the good things is that if
you work with 1 pixel equals 1
DIP and that baseline
density, than it
uses the correct values.
So you don't have to
do any doubling
or halving or anything.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Yeah, so the thing we're kind
of hammering home here is,
layout is DIPs.
Forget about physical pixels.
Layout equals DIPs.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
We've said it about five times.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: If we go on to
the next slide, one slight
variation on DIPs is when we're
talking about text sizing.
This is very closely related
to DIPs, but we had to
introduce the ability
to use it.
It has the ability to scale the
text up and down as a user
preference.
These really are kind of
accessibility features.
Some users just need to
have larger text.
So whenever you're sizing any
text for your layouts, you
need to be using this SP unit,
scale-independent pixel.
And if the user's not changed
their scale, then 1 SP will
equal 1 DP.
But you need to bear in mind
that the user can bump that
both up and down.
So you kind of get, like, 1.2x
or 1.4x the size if you're
bumping it up, or it might
be slightly smaller.
So you need to respect that
user's chosen setting up and
scale your text in SPs.
ROMAN NURIK: So that means if
you actually have two content
blocks, two pieces of text that
are adjacent, make sure
that the spacing between them,
for example, scales
with the text size.
You also want to use SP units
for the margins, for example.
Generally we use SP units for
the text size attributes, but
they're useful in other cases
when you want to be very
cognizant of spacing between
text and things like that.
NICK BUTCHER: There's a good
way to test your app.
If you're worried, you know, you
want to test your layouts
to the extreme, then change the
language to German and put
the scaling feature up to
maximum and see how your
layout handles it.
ROMAN NURIK: So we gotta
fly through the rest.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ROMAN NURIK: Let's
fly through.
So--
NICK BUTCHER: So last
[INAUDIBLE].
I was going to say, though, so
yeah, when we're talking about
layout, then you want to go
about physical pixels.
But when we're talking about
bitmap assets, then you
absolutely need to
think in pixels.
So if there's anything that
changes when you go to, sorf
of like the zoom from Nexus 10,
which has the same kind of
layout size in DIPs, is you need
your assets to be crisp.
If you were just to use the
exact same assets from an MDPI
advice on an XHDPI device, then
they'll be super blurry.
So this is where we
introduce this
concept of density buckets.
It lets [INAUDIBLE] nothing
about raw density, but kind of
group them together into these
logical densities here.
So as we've talked about all
along, we have this MDPI
bucket, or 160 DPI, is our
baseline, kind of where all
the first Android devices
came out.
And slowly that's kind of
drifted upwards until we're at
the range now where XHDPI is the
normal on most phones, and
XX seems to be perhaps
coming in.
So the idea here is if you have
an icon, like we show you
here in the right-hand column,
which needs to be 32 by 32
DIPs, on an MDPI device,
that would translate
into 32 by 32 pixels.
But on an XHDPI device, that
would actually turn out to be
64 by 64 pixels.
So you have complete control
over a pixel-perfect icon in
an XHDPI device.
You can draw it at 64 by 64, and
then the device will pick
the right density version
at run time.
ADAM KOCH: All right.
ROMAN NURIK: Go ahead.
Go ahead.
ADAM KOCH: The DPI buckets
highlighted in bold, just
quickly here, they're some of
the key density buckets.
So you should generally provide
all your assets in
those densities.
The other ones are sort of
less common, but you may
potentially want to provide
key assets in those
densities as well.
It's sort of your call there,
especially XXHDPI for your
[INAUDIBLE].
All right, let's go.
NICK BUTCHER: So a lot of people
ask, can I just provide
the highest-density ones
an have Android scale
it down and so forth?
And that is [INAUDIBLE]
you can do.
There's a slight performance
hit.
It's not huge, but it's
something to be aware of.
And Roman's going to come back
to talk about some techniques
you can use to actually
do this a
little bit more smartly.
But moving forward to the next
slide, this is kind of the
concept I wanted to talk about,
is that you don't
really want to design your
application specifically
around a certain device.
Because the device landscape's
changing all the time, and you
kind of end up chasing
your tail.
So using these techniques,
only thinking in DIPs for
layout and only thinking about
density for pixel assets, for
bitmap assets, is your route to
happiness for future devices.
So the example [INAUDIBLE]
going back to here is, if you
have provided a layout for
something like the Motorola
Xoom, the first generation of
Android tablets that came out,
which was like 1280 by 800,
and you had provided XHDPI,
these high-density bitmap
asset for something like the
Galaxy Nexus, all of a sudden,
when a device like the Nexus 10
comes out-- which you might
not have heard about a year
ago, when you did this--
it'll pick the same layouts
as the Motorola Xoom.
It'll pick the high-density
bitmap assets from the phones
and I put them together, and
have this optimized-looking
layout and clear assets.
So it's a really, really nice
system to be able to think
about these two things
separately.
ROMAN NURIK: Moving on.
Really quick, pixel grid tips.
So when you're doing asset
production, this is actually
one general tip, and you can
tweak this as you see fit.
One thing that I generally do
is I use a 4-pixel grid for
designing assets, and
I start with XHDPI.
So you can see here, starting
with XHDPI, lining things up
to a 4-pixel grid means that
you can actually then scale
down to HDPI, MDPI, and I'm
not sure about LDPI, but
probably LDPI as well, and get
really, really crisp borders.
So this is actually something
that we do
in our system assets.
So if you look at the default
button asset, the pressed
state for the button, you'll
notice that the size of the
glow around the core
shape is 8 pixels.
And the reason for that, the
reason it's not 7 pixels or 5
pixels is that it scales down
really, really nicely.
So this is just a quick tip if
you're doing asset production.
Aligning to a 4-pixel grid is
really, really useful for
scaling down.
OK.
So that was it for
units of measure.
We flew through them.
We're still over time.
Let's really briefly talk
about design news.
Actually, before we jump into
that, any parting thoughts on
pixels and DIPs and
things like that?
No?
ADAM KOCH: Layouts.
Layouts, DIPs.
Always use them.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Layouts and DIPs.
OK.
So design news.
The first is we actually have
a New York Android Designers
Meet-Up coming up next week.
This is the very first Meet-Up,
and we're hoping to
have multiple of these
Meet-Ups over
the next few months.
I don't know how frequently
we'll do it, but definitely
something that we're
starting up now.
This is actually run by Paul
Burke from the Android
Designers Google+ Community.
So if you're in New York or the
general area and you're
free next Thursday at around
6:30 or 7:00 PM Eastern, then
visit this link and we'll
see you there.
ADAM KOCH: Looks like
we lost Nick there.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh. looks like we
lost Nick in the Hangout.
OK.
Thanks, Pete.
Pete's producing.
And the last item in our Design
News is the Android UI
design kit.
So Taylor Ling has this design
kit that's a nice starting
point, a nice template for doing
sorts of visual designs.
And if you're interested
in doing this--
and I don't know which
devices he has, but
probably various devices.
If you're interested in getting
a nice, easy starting
point with a couple of patterns
already pre-packaged
in there, then this is
a nice starter kit.
I think we see ourselves
twice now.
It's kind of cool.
There's Nick.
ADAM KOCH: This is what we
get for going over time.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So yeah.
So that's his updated version
of the UI design kit.
All right.
And I think that's it for
the content today.
Any parting thoughts, fellas?
No?
Nick is still super frozen.
Well, thanks again for joining
Android Design in Action.
I'm your host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Adam Koch.
And over in Mountain View, we
have Nick Butcher, who is
frozen right now.
ROMAN NURIK: Absolutely
frozen.
ADAM KOCH: Thanks, guys.
See you next week.
ROMAN NURIK: Thanks, see you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]